صهيب هذه التغطيه طبعا مستمره معك
واعتقال مسرب الوثائق السريه
وهذا المسؤول عن هذا التسريب الخطير عمره
21 عاما اذا كما نتابع في هذه التغطيه
وجراء القبض عليه قبل قليل ونتابع ايضا في
هذه التغطيه ومتابعه المزيد من التفاصيل
شكرا لك راويه اذا مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم
في تغطيه خبر الساعه نذكر بالاخبار العجله
التي وردت حتى الان ما نعرفه اذا حيث اعلن
وزير العدل الامريكي امريكا
وحسب الوزير فان المجتبى به المسمى جاك
دوجلا يعمل في سلاح الجو التابع للحرس
الوطني الامريكي
اذا هذا عاجل اذا تقول ان المجتمع به في
تسريب وثائق البانتاجون سيمثل غدا امام
محكمه المختصه في بوسطن وقلت شبكه
المعتقل هو
المشتبه به بتسريب هذه الوثائق السريه
لديه اراء غير تقليديه فيما يخص سياسه
امريكا واشرت الى انه وضع قيودا على
السلاح وكان يحاول لفت انتباه المنتسبين
الى التطبيق الذي نشر عليه الوثائق السريه
من جانبها قالت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان
المعتقل قد يواجه توهما تصل الى 10 سنوات
عن كل جرم مشيره الى انه سيواجه تهمه
الحاق الضرر بالولايات المتحده
من جانبه اعلن البنت تحقيقات لا تزال
مستمره بشان مسرب الوثائق السريه وايضا
حول ما اثير عبر وسائل الاعلام عن محتوى
تلك الوثائق
مثلما قال الوزير اوستن البنتاجون ياخذ
موضوعه تسريبات الوثائق على محمل الجد
وصلنا العمل الاستخباراتي على مدار الساعه
لكشف ملابسات الامر وكيفيه السير التحقيق
بشان مسرب الوثائق السريه وماذا سنتحدث عن
الوثائق المسربه الحساسه على خاصه لا اثير
عبر وسائل الاعلام عن محتوى تلك الوثائق
معنى مباشره من واشنطن المراسل العربيه
حسين طوط حسين اهلا بك معنا او سيكون معنا
ايضا مباشره بعد قليل مراسلنا من هناك
ولكن مشاهدينا ايضا نذكركم بخبر الساعه
الذي نغطيه اذا منذ فتره في هذه الفتره
المسائيه اذا القبض على المشتبه بانه
المسؤول عن تسريب الوثائق السريه في
البانتاجون والتي احدثت ضجه حول العالم
المعروف عنه اذا حسب وزير العدل الامريكي
بانه جرى توقيفه اذا في قضيه الوثائق
المسربه في هذه الصور في منطقه في مصر
شوستس الامريكيه اذا وهو كان يعمل في
استخبارات الحرس الوطني الامريكي اذا معنا
الان دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في الشؤون
السياسيه الامريكيه دكتور عقيل اهلا بك
معنا السؤال المطروح بدايه هو كيف لهذا
المجند وعمره 21 سنه ان تكون له الصلاحيه
الى الوصول الى وثائق بهذا القدر من
الحساسيه
شكرا لك هو هذه واحده من الاسئله المحيره
الكبرى ليس فقط انه يعني من الدرجات
الواطئه الدنيا في المنظومه العسكري
الامريكيه لكنه ايضا من الحرس الوطني
والحرس الوطني في العاده لا يتعاطى مع
معلومات بهذا المقدار من السريه هذه عاده
يتعاطى معها يعني الحرس الوطني في
الولايات المتحده هو قوه رديفه يستطيع
رئيس الولايات المتحده ان يدعوها
للانخراط في حال حصول كارثه طبيعيه في
الولايات المتحده دعم القوات الامريكيه
المقاتله الفعاله في مكان ما يعني ليست
قوه اساسيه او رئيسيه
ويبدو غريبا ان معلومات
مهمه كهذه مرت عبر طاوله او عمل هذا الشخص
علينا ايضا ان نعرف اذا هل هو من الحرس
الوطني الفعال ام الاحتياط لان الفرس
الوطني هناك وهو على كلتا الحالتين ستكون
هناك مشكله ولكن ما هي دوافعه برايك جاك
تكسير هذا المجلد عمره 21 سنه في الحرس
الوطني الامريكي هل تعتقد انه دوافعه هي
الشهره لفت الانتباه الايجو ايجو
المراهقين يريد ان يظهر على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بانه لديه معلومات سريه عن
الامن القومي الامريكي ام ربما هناك اسباب
اخرى او دوافع اخرى قد يكون مجندا لصالح
دوله اخرى ربما
يعني انا لا اعتقد لحد الان
ظهر ان لديه دوافع ايديولوجيه او دوافع
مرتبطه بالدول الاخرى
مرتبطه بالتجسس ان كانت دوافع مرتبطه
بالتجسس لدوله اخرى يعني لكان يعني اعتنى
كثيرا بعمليه تسريب هذه الوثائق واضح جدا
انه التسريب لم يكن حاذقا يعني اخذ
الوثائق اخرجها لحد الان يعني ما رشح
اخرجها من المكان طبعها اخذها ثم على
الطاوله حتى المجلات التي على الطاوله
ظهرت يعني ليس عملا لشخص فني مدرب على
التجسس هذا اولا يبدو ايضا يعني الحديث عن
عن عن نوعيه هذا الشخص انه انطوائي بعيد
عن الناس يحب البنادق
شخصيه تحب الحياه اون لاين
والذي حدثوا انه اراد ان يجلب الانتباه
لنفسه
وشارك هذه الوثائق على الاقل هذا ما يبدو
لحد الان شارك هذه الوثائق في مكان وحتى
الذين
عرفوا بهذه الوثائق وتحدثت معهم الاشبياء
لم يكونوا يعرفونه وانما تحدثوا عن
انطباعاتهم عنه من خلال هذا البرنامج الذي
كان يشاركهم مع الاخرين يتحدثون على ما
اعتقد
بالضبط يعني احد الذين معهم البنتاجون او
الاف بي اي يعني شخص مراهق الذي مثلا ساعد
في الوصول الى الى هذا الشخص يبدو القضيه
مرتبطه بجلب الانتباه جلب الانتباه
جميل طيب يجهز معنا الان مراسلنا اذا من
واشنطن حسين طاود حسين تسمعني الان
نعم اسمع حسين اذا بتنا نعرف اسم المشتبه
به بتسريب وثائق السريه ونشاهد اذا في هذه
الصور لحظه اعتقالهم من
قباله منزله في مصر اسمه جاك تكسيرا عمره
21 عاما ما الذي تمكنت من جمعه من معلومات
حول مسرب وثائق البنك
بحسب ما قرانا صهيب بان هذا الشاب يحب فرض
شخصيات شخصيته وهو شخصيه قويه كما قال احد
اعضاء المجموعه التي كان يتواصل معها
والتي سرب لها هذه المعلومات هو يحب
الظهور يحب ان يفرض نفسه على هذه المجموعه
ان يكون قياديا ان يشعر من معه بانهم
يحتاجون لا ولكن دعني فقط اوضح مساله
بالنسبه
للتهم التي ستوجه التي قد تتوجه له حسب
وزير العدل هذه التوست توجه لها بحسب
قانون التجسس اي هذا القانون يجرم افشاء
السريه عن المعلومات وعن الوثائق السريه
التي قد تستخدم للحاق الضرر في الولايات
المتحده كل وثيقه من هذه من هذه الوثائق
صهيب لها تهام خاصه بها عقوبه الادانه تصل
الى السجل عشر سنوات عن كل تهمه هذا
بالنسبه لموضوع توم هو حتى الان بعدما تم
اعتقال اعتقاله من قبل الاف بي اي لم توجه
له سيذهب سياخذونه الى المحكمه الفدراليه
في ولايه
حيث يتم تحقيق معه وسيتم ربما توجيه تهم
له حتى له هو مشتبه
هناك الكثير من المعلومات نحن بحاجه
لمعرفتها عن هذا الشخص عن دوافعه الجميع
الان يتساءل ما هي دوافع هذا الشاب هل هي
دوافع كما يقال بانه يحب الظهور ام انه
بالفعل هو مرتبط بجهاز تجسسي خارجي عند
اذن هناك نوع قضيه اخرى وهناك مستوى اخر
من التعامل معه
وخطوره اكبر اذا كان بالفعل طلب منه
الحصول على هذه المعلومات ونشرها ولكن
طبعا السؤال الكبير الان وكيف تمكن هذا
الشاب طبعا هو لحد الان هو ما يزال مشتبها
به بانه هو المسؤول عن تسريب المعلومات
ولكن
السؤال هو كيف تمكن او كيف تمكن من الحصول
على الصلاحيه على الوصول الى هكذا وثائق
بهذا القدر من الاهميه دعني اسالك اذا
توافرت اي معلومات عن الاجراءات الاضافيه
الاحتياطيه التي فرضها البانتاجون بعد
حدوث هذا التسريب
حتى الان لم يفصل هذه الاجراءات الا انه
اعلن انه سيتخذها لتفادي حدوث مثل هذا
الاختراق مثل هذا التسريب خاصه ان ذلك
ياتي بعد نحو عقد من الزمن على تسريبات
ووثائق التي وضعت من اجلها اجراءات جديده
وبروتوكولات امنيه جديده لمنع حدوث هكذا
تسريبات ياتي بعد عشر سنوات شاب في 21 من
عمره لا حسب ما فهمنا حتى الان المعلومات
ما زالت غامضه ولكن حسب ما فهمنا من كلام
المسؤولين بانه ليس لديه تصريح امني
للوصول الى هكذا
هكذا معلومات ولكنه استطاع الولوج الى
اليها اذا هذا خلق امني بطبيعه الحال لن
تكون كما قلنا لكم كما قال المتحدث باسمه
سيتخذ هذه الخطوات لحمايه امن المعلومات
التي لديه وتوزيعها ولمن يستطيع الاطلاع
عليها ولكن لم يفصل بدقه ننتظر ان نحصل
على معلومات ربما اكثر خلال الاسابيع
القادمه خاصه مع تزايد الدعوات في مجلس
النواب ومجلس الشيوخ في الكونجرس من اجل
عقد جلسات استماع لاطلاع المشرعين عليها
هذه الجلسات بعضها سيكون علنيا نستطيع ان
الاطلاع على ما ياتي بها وما يجري فيها
ولكن الجلسات المهمه والاكثر بطبيعه الحال
ستكون سريه كما اعتدنا هذا لكن سيكون هناك
ربما تسريبات من هذه الجلسات حول هذه
الاجراءات وربما يكون لك اعلان رسمي من
قبل ان تضع عن بعضها ايضا نعم طيب اعود
الى ضيفي اذا كذلك دكتور عقيل عباس دكتور
عقيل
المتوافر حتى الان المعلومات حول
بانه كان موظفا في
الحرس الوطني من قوات الدفاع الجوي في مصر
وهو انضم في السادس والعشرين من سبتمبر
هل تعتقد ان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه تعاني
خللا في حمايه المعلومات السريه
ما مكن هذا الشاب اليافع من الوصول الى
هذه المعلومات بهذا القدر من الحساسيه
واضح
مدخل خلل
ليس فقط خلل واضحا وانما خللا جسيما انه
بعض الوثائق التي سربت هي ما يسمى تلخيصات
تعطى لرئيس الولايات المتحده ان على طاوله
رئيس الولايات المتحده ويستطيع يعني شاب
بهذا العمر بهذه الدرجه الدنيا في الحرس
الوطني ان يصل اليها
عندما حصلت ويكيليكس في وقت يعني حدثت
الكثير من الاجراءات من اجل تقليل عدد
الناس او المختصين في الاجهزه العسكريه
الامريكيه الذين يستطيعون الوصول الى
معلومات حساسه اقل حساسيه بكثير من هذه
المعلومات يعني
التي اثارت الضجه معظم المعلومات كانت على
مستوى واطئ رسائل او تقارير من قاده
الوحدات في العراق يبعثونها للبنتاجون
رسائل من الدبل في السفارات يبعثون على
وزاره الخارجيه لكن ليس الخرائط والوثائق
التي تهيئها قياده الجيوش الامريكيه كي
تطلع الرئيس بايدن عليها هذا شخص واحد فقط
يعني
خلل واضح وجسيم نعم طيب بالحديث على قضيه
ويكيليكس دكتور
هناك من يرى هناك اختلاف اساسي بانه وقتها
المسؤول عن تسريبات ويكيليبس عفوا كان
تقصد الحصول على هذه المعلومات بينما اذا
ثبت ان هذا الشاب هذا الموظف
الجديد نسبيا من 2019 اذا كانت دوافعه فقط
بحثا عن الشهره او للفت الانتباه هل يختلف
الامر في مساله ادانته او الحكم عليه
طبعا هذا يعتمد الامر على نوعيه المحاكمه
هذه ما ستكون محكمه اتحاديه فيدراليه
وليست محكمه ولايه
وتعتمد على قضيه الاسباب المخففه اذا
يستطيع انه مثلا
يثبت عن طريق التقارير نفسيه انه لديه
اشكالات شيء من هذا القبيل
بخصوص
برادلي قبل ان يتحول الى انثى كان هناك
موقف
ايديولوجي من الموضوع لكن كان ايضا هناك
اضطرابات نفسيه الشخص كان وحيدا بعيدا
يعمل ساعات طويله ثم يعني اقنعه طرف اخر
للقيام بهذه تردد فتره من الزمن الى ان
قام بالعمليه بخصوص هذا الشخص لا نعرف
اعتقد الاشكاليه الاولى انه هو يعني في
مجموعه من المراهقين المجموعه التي كان
عليها اون لاين من عشرين الى ثلاثين
معظمهم من المراهقين هو كان بين الاكبر
سنا بين هذه المجموعه وسرب هذه الوثائق
وكرر العمليه
والى انه اخذها شخص من هذه المجموعه
وسربها في مكان اخر ثم انتشرت تدريجيا
فانا اعتقد السياق هنا يعني الكثير واضح
انه هذا الشخص لا يقصد الضرر لا يقصد انه
هذه المعلومات تخرج في قصه برادلي الشخص
كان يقصد ويعرف ان المعلومات ستظهر ولديه
موقف ايديولوجي انه من حق الناس ان تعرف
بينما هذا له اسبابها النفسيه الخاصه يعني
يعتمد على كيف سيستخدم الدفاع مثل يعني
مثل هذه الامكانيات في تخفيف الحكم عليه
لكن ينتظره طويل في السجن نعم اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا على هذه المداخله معنا الدكتور عقيل
في الشؤون السياسيه الامريكيه كنت معنا من
واشنطن مشاهدينا لمن التحق بنا في هذه
اللحظات انتم تشاهدون على الشاشه صور
توقيف مشتبه به بانه هو المسؤول عن تسريب
وثائق وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البنطلون
والتي احدثت ضجه حول العالم تسريبات تحتوي
على تلخيصات من الاستخبارات الامريكيه
للرئيس الامريكي حول ما يجري في عديد
الملفات هذا الشاب بهذا السروال الاحمر
القصير عمره 21 عاما اسمه جاك تكسيرا وكان
يعمل في الحرس الوطني الامريكي بمصاص
والتحق بالحرس الوطني الامريكي في عام
يعتقد بانه قام بالحصول على هذه المعلومات
السريه عن الامن القومي الامريكي وعن
تقييمات حول الوضع في اوكرانيا وغيرها من
الملفات
ومشاركتها مع عدد من اصدقائه على منصه على
الانترنت تدعى منصه ديسكورد وبعدها تسربت
وعلى نطاق واسع حول العالم واحدثت ضررا
كبيرا طبعا في علاقات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وكان هناك العديد من المواقف
اذن
نتابع ايضا مشاهدينا مع كذلك اخر الاخبار
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الاف بي اي
القى القبض على المجتمع به في تسريب وثائق
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ويدعى جاك تكسيرا
فمن هو تكسيرا نتابع ايضا
[موسيقى]
معنى الالم من واشنطن طارق الشامي المحلل
السياسي استاذ طارق اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه يعني بالنظر الى ما تحتويه هذه
الوثائق التي يعتقد ان جاك التكسيرا هو
الذي قام بمشاركتها على منصه ديسكورد
برايك ما حجم الضرر الذي الحقته هذه
التسريبات في علاقات واشنطن الخارجيه
بالتاكيد هناك كثير من الضرر يعني اول هذه
الاضرار انه يجعل الجهات الامنيه الاخرى
التي تتعاون مع الولايات المتحده مثل يعني
مجموعه الخمسه او العيون الخمس كما يطلق
عليها وتشمل الدول الناطقه بالانجليزيه
والتي ترتبط بالولايات المتحده مثل
بريطانيا وكندا ونيوزيلندا واستراليا هم
يتبادلون هذه المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
فاذا تسربت معلومات استخباراتيه كانت احدى
الدول قد اعطتها للولايات المتحده فهذا
يسبب حرجا ويجعل هناك ثقه يعني عدم ثقه في
مدى احتفاظ وقدره الولايات المتحده على
الاحتفاظ بهذه الاسرار هو ايضا يضر لانه
كشف على ان الولايات المتحده تتجسس على
اقرب حلفائها مثل كوريا الجنوبيه واسرائيل
وبريطانيا وغيرها من الدول بما فيها بعض
الدول الشرق الاوسط كل هذا كشفته بعض
التسريبات التي نشرت على على ديسكورد ثم
انتقلت الى تيليجرام وتويتر هذا ايضا يضر
كذلك بالاوكرانيين لانه كشف عن ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تعاني من ضعف او عدم وجود
ذخائر كافيه لقوات الدفاع الجوي ربما
تكفيها لعده اسابيع وهذا يكشفها امام
الروس ويجعلهم يغيرون ربما هل يمكن ما دام
انها تبين على ان اوكرانيا في موقف ضعف هل
يمكن ان تكون روسيا لها يد في موضوع هذه
التسريبات او تكون يعني وراء هذا المجند
في الحرس الوطني الامريكي
لا احد يعلم على وجه اليقين لان هذا ربما
ما تكشفه التحقيقات هناك تفاصيل كثيره
ربما لا نعلمها بالاضافه الى انه هو ايضا
كشف عن عجز في القوات الروسيه هو احرج
ايضا الروس وبين المدى الذي وصلت اليه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه في اختراق الاجهزه
الامنيه والجيش الروسي نفسها واعتراض
اتصالاتهم ومعرفه اماكنهم وما الى ذلك كل
هذا يضع الروس في موضع ايضا حرج جدا
بالمقارنه ما تدعي روسيا دائما بان اقوى
عظمى وانها قادره على يعني الانتصار في
اوكرانيا هذا ممكن يعني قد يكون ذلك ممكن
لكن لا احد يعلم على وجه الدقه يعني ما
الذي يمكن ان تصل اليه التفاصيل خصوصا وان
يعني
هو يبدو هو كان يعلم ما يفعل لكنه لم ينشر
هذه يعني هذه دقائق على على ديسكورد شخص
اخر من المجموعه التي تبادل معها
المعلومات هو الذي فعل ذلك وربما فعل ذلك
عن قصد ربما تكون روسيا لها علاقه
بالموضوع او دول اخرى لاحد يعلم لكن هو
يعني يعني في حقيقه الامر هو يعمل في مجال
استخبارات يعني هو ليس بعيدا هو في جناح
الاستخبارات في الحرس الوطني والحرس
الوطني وليس فقط رديف وانما هو ايضا شارك
في حرب العراق وشارك في معارك كبيره وهو
ايضا يحق لهم الحصول على المعلومات السريه
وهذا ليس بغريب هو هو فقط ربما كانت لديه
يعني انا العليا التي يريد يعني
نعم نعم طيب ولكن حتى مع ذلك عندما يكون
لديه هذا النوع من الانا المفروض ان يكون
هناك مسؤوليه في هكذا وظائف حساسه يمكن ان
يكون له اكسس او صلاحيه الوصول الى هذه
المعلومات
عنوانه الوظيفي او يعني لقبه الوظيفي هو
سايبر ترانسبورت سيستمز في سلاح الجو
الامريكي في يعني هو مراقب انظمه النقل
السيبراني هل هكذا موظفين على هذا المستوى
بامكانهم الوصول الى هذه المعلومات بكل
سهوله برايك
يعني هناك ثلاثه ملايين شخص في الولايات
المتحده لديهم يعني
تصاريح السريه تصاريح الامنيه السريه على
اختلاف مستوياتها هناك مستويات عديده هذا
تكسير ربما كان يحصل حسبما تقول الصحف
الامريكيه على وهو درجه عاليه من درجات
السريه وبالتالي وظيفته تقتضي ذلك بمعنى
اخر انه وظيفته كانت تقتضي المعرفه هذه
المعلومات وهو لكي يتحصل على هذه
المعلومات حصل على هذا
السري للغايه حتى
يستطيع ان يحافظ على المعلومات ما فعله هو
خرق للاتفاق الذي تم مع الحكومه الامريكيه
في هذا الصدد وبالمناسبه ليس فقط الذين
يعملون في الحكومه او في الجيش الذين
يحصلون على هذه التصاريح الامنيه هناك
موظفون مدنيون يعملون في شركات ترتبط
بوزاره الدفاع يحصلون على هذه التصاريح
الامنيه وبالتالي هناك عدد كبير جدا هناك
الان مراجحه فعليه واقعيه بانه يجب اعاده
النظر في مدى اتساع هذه يعني هذه القاعده
من الاحتفاظ بالسريه لدى عدد كبير من
الناس وانه يجب تحديدها في يعني مجموعات
معينه بحيث لا يمكن لشخص في الحرس الوطني
ان يحصل على نفس المعلومات التي يمكن ان
يحصل عليها يعني رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه او وزير الدفاع او مش تحدثنا
كثيرا عن عمليه توقيفه
ووظيفته وعمره كذلك وانه ربما دوافع كذلك
توضع في اطار يعني ربما رغبه في لفت
الانتباه ولكن ماذا عن الوثائق المسربه
نفسها استاذ طارق
من ناحيه خطورتها ما نعلمه الان انه منها
يعني عباره عن ملخصات تعطى للرئيس
الامريكي عن الاوضاع في
عديد الدول
التي تربط بينها وبين الولايات المتحده
يعني علاقات او هناك يعني ملفات راهنه
فيها ماذا نعرف عما تحتويه هذه التسريبات
يعني هناك الكثير الذي تم نشره بالفعل
وهناك ما تم نفيه يعني على سبيل المثال تم
نفي ان مصر كانت تخطط لارسال اسلحه الى
الروس نفته القاهره ونفته ايضا واشنطن
ويبدو ان هذا لم يكن حقيقيا لا احد يعلم
ما هي ايضا دقه هذه الوثائق كما ان
الولايات المتحده نفسها تعترف بان بعض
الوثائق تم التلاعب بها على سبيل المثال
تم تضخيم عدد
الضحايا الاوكر عدد الضحايا الروس هذا نعم
هذا ما يعني يقولونه لذلك تجد ان
الاوكرانيين يتهمون الروس بانهم هم الذين
فعلوا ذلك
من مصلحتهم التلاعب في هذه الوثائق لكن
هناك طبعا وثائق اخرى خطيره جدا عن تشكيل
القوات
الاوكرانيه عن متى تصل المساعدات
الامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا ايضا
النقاط الضعف في الجيش الروسي وكيفيه
الاختراق هذا ايضا من شانه ان يساعد الروس
على
الاخذ بحضرهم في المرات القادمه ومعرفه
كيف تم التنصت عليهم من قبل
السلطات الامريكيه او الاستخبارات
الامريكيه ما يجعلهم
يغيرون
في كيفيه تبادل المعلومات فيما بينهم
وكيفيه تشكيل قواتهم وما الى ذلك ايضا هو
اضر بكوريا الجنوبيه التي كان فيها يعني
احتداد كبير بين النخبه السياسيه هناك حول
ارسال ذخائر ومساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا
وهم لم يكونوا على ما يبدو راغبين في ذلك
لانهم لا يريدون التورط في الصراع بشكل
مباشر لكن تحت الضغط الامريكي ربما كانوا
يحاولون ذلك الكشف عن الوثيقه هو احرجهم
ايضا بشكل كبير بالاضافه الى اسرائيل التي
ايضا كشفت يعني الوثائق على ان
الموساد جهاز الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي كان
يعني يشجع المتظاهرين ويدعمهم
للمدنيين للاعتراض على عمليه
التغييرات القضائيه التي في المحكمه
العليا التي كان نتنياهو وحكومته يريدون
القيام بها وبالتالي هناك كثير من
المعلومات المحرجه للغايه والتي
ايضا ان الولايات المتحده تتجسس على
حلفائها وهذا صحيح ان الكل يعلم ذلك وهذا
ليس بجديد الاستخبارات عاده ما تفعل ذلك
حتى في الشرق والغرب يتجسسون على بعضهم
البعض وليس فقط في النواحي العسكريه وانما
ايضا في النواحي الاقتصاديه والتجسس على
التكنولوجيا والى ذلك ولكن ان تكشف ذلك
علنا هو يسبب قدر كبير من الاحراج للقاده
والسياسيين امام الشعوب اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
طارق شامي المحلل السياسي كنت معنا من
العاصمه واشنطن
ومعنى الان من نيويورك المدعي العامه
الامريكيه السابق سيدنيك شكرا على انضمامك
الينا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه جاك
تكسيرس يمثل غدا امام محكمه في بوسطن من
التهم التي ستوجه اليه وما المنتظر كذلك
حول مصيره وفي هذا المثول غدا امام
المحكمه في بوسطن
التي سوف توجه له سوف تركز على التجسس وهي
تهم خطيره للغايه وتؤدي الى السجن لعشر او
عشرين عاما واستطيع ان اقول ان مستقبله لا
يبدو مشرق ما قام به هو عمل سارق بالنسبه
لشخص في الجيش وتم تدريبه على التعامل مع
الوثائق الغايه في السريه فهو ليس لديه اي
ذريعه للقيام بما قام به نعم ولكن سيدني
الحديث الان على انه دوافع جاك تكسيرا
توضع في اطار محاوله لفت الانتباه او يعني
التباهي امام اصدقائه على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي بان لديه معلومات سريه
عن الدول
وعن امريكا كذلك هل يمكن ان يخفف هذا من
الحكم عليه بالنظر مثلا اذا قضيه لانه كان
هناك وراءها دافع ايولوجي
اعتقد انه لا يمكن
مقارنه
حاله ويكيليكس ولكن هو طبعا نشر معلومات
سريه سواء قام بذلك
للتظاهر بان لديه معلومات مع اصدقائه
ولكنه قد شارك معلومات
تؤثر على الامن القومي الامريكي في نهايه
المطاف ليس هناك شكل في ذلك اما بالنسبه
للحكم الذي سوف يصدر ضده نحن لا نعلم
الكثير عن ذلك نعلم ان هناك اشخاص لهم صله
بهذا الحادث ولكن نريد ان نقف على ادوار
هؤلاء هذه التفاصيل ليست متاحه لدينا في
الوقت الراهن نعم طيب ولكن سيدنا حتى الان
ما يزال هناك تسميه
بانه مشتبه به بانه يكون مسؤولا عن تسريب
هذه الوثائق هل تعتقد ان عمليه التوقيف من
قبل الاف بي اي تثبت على انه يعني هذا هو
الشخص المسؤول ام ربما سيكون هناك فصول
اخرى او مشتبهين اخرين او متورطين اخرين
في عمليه التسريب سيمثلون امام القضاء
كذلك
اعتقد ان هناك مشتبه بهم اخر ولكن السؤال
هو حول مدى حصولهم على المعلومات ومقاموا
بها لمن اعطوها وصلوها
واستطيع ان اؤكد لك بان الاف بي اي يحقق
الان في اماكن اخرى يقوم
مصادره اجهزه كمبيوتر اخرى لكن المشكله
الكبيره هي لماذا استطاع هذا شخصا يصل الى
هذه المعلومات السريه للغايه هو كان مجرد
مجند في
الحرس الجوي الوطني وقد استطاع ان يصل الى
معلومات غايه في السريه اذا السؤال الذي
يطرح هو كيف يمكن لهذا الشخص ان يحصل على
هذه المعلومات ولماذا كانت هذه المعلومات
موجوده في القاعده العسكريه في
ولا يبدو ان ايا من هذه المعلومات لها صله
بما يقوم به اي شخص او اي جندي في هذه
القاعده العسكري نعم طيب شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد انك اكرمن انت المدعي العام الامريكي
سابق كنت معنا من نيويورك
مشاهدينا كيف بدات قصه نشر هذه التسريبات
العسكريه الامريكيه ومن اين ومن هو جاك
تكسيرا الذي ورط نفسه في نشر هذه الوثائق
السريه نتابع
هنا بدات القصه موقع ديسكورد
لقاء افتراضي لحوالي 30 فردا دردشه
اعتياديه لا غير شباب ومراهقين دقائق حتى
تحول الحديث دون قصد لتبادل الاهتمامات في
مناقشه الحرب في اوكرانيا وهنا وقع
المحظور
شاب عشرني يدير مجموعه دردشه يعمل منذ عام
في الحرس الوطني الجوي الامريكي نشرت
تلقائيا عشرات الوثائق العسكريه
جاك تكسيرا احرج امريكا واربك العالم بلا
قصد
الشرطه الامريكيه لم يغمض لها جفن
[موسيقى]
قبضت على تكسيرا للتحقيق في تسريبات وصل
صداها العالم غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى المشاهدين القبض على جاكتكسيرا كان
خبر الساعه الرئيس نذهب الان الى مجموعه
اخرى من اخبار الساعه حيث عقد نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده الفريق اول محمد حمدانو
اجتماعا مشتركا عبر الهاتف مع مبعوثي
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
والنرويج للسودان الاجتماع باحث التطورات
السياسيه وجهود استكمال العمليه السياسيه
كذلك واكد دجله على الالتزام بما تم
توقيعه عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي كما انه
اكد للمبعوثين على ضروره خروج المؤسسات
العسكريه من العمل السياسي من جانبهم اكد
المبعوثون على دعم الاتفاق الايطالي بوصفه
الاساس لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه المقبله في
السودان
هذا واثارت قاعده مروي الجويه خلافا بين
المكونات العسكريه المختلفه المتمثله
بالقوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الرد
السريع
قاعده مروي الجويه قد تفجر الصراع مجددا
في السودان بين المكونات العسكريه
المختلفه اهالي مروي تفاجئوا بعشرات
المركبات العسكريه التابعه للقوات الدعم
السريع تنتشر في مدينتهم وتطوق المطار
تظاهر رفضا لما جرى وتاييدا للقوات
المسلحه واعاده تمركز القوات
يخالف مهام نظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات اللجان الامنيه
المركزيه والولائيه واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما
الى المزيد من الانقسامات والتوترات التي
ربما تقود الى انفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد
موقف القوات المسلحه نفته قوات الدعم
السريع وصفه تحركاتها بالطبيعيه والتي تم
تنسيقها مع قياده القوات المسلحه ضمن
تاديه مهامها وواجباتها
سبق لقائد قوه الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو ان وعد بحل الخلافه مع الجيش والذهاب
للانتخابات النزيهه الدوردا دايرين
انتخابات حره نزيهه الشعب السوداني ان شاء
الله جاب لنا
لم تجعل انتخابات بل واجلت التوقيع على
اتفاق السياسي النهائي بين الاطراف
السياسيه لاجل غير مسمى فالاطراف العسكريه
لم تتفق ولم تدمج قوات الدعم السريع في
صفوف الجيش تقدر اعداد قوات الدعم السريع
بالالاف بدات تتشكل عام 2003 اسست رسميا
عام 2013 وتعمل تحت التسلسل قيادي بموجب
قانون خاص
[موسيقى]
الى الحرب في اوكرانيا ومع خفوت صوت
المعارك وثبات الجبهات في اوكرانيا تتصاعد
وحده الهجمات السيبرانيه والاتهامات
بالوقوف وراءها بين كييف وموسكو وحلفائهما
حيث اتهمت روسيا الولايات المتحده ودول
الناتو بشن هجمات من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بهدف التمويه انك هي من تقوم بهذه الهجمات
التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
هذه ليست الحرب الوحيده في اوكرانيا خلف
هذه النيران تدور حرب اخرى غير تقليديه
تصل عمق الاراضي الروسيه والاوكرانيه
والحلفاء ايضا جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي
وامريكا بشن هجمات واسعه النطاق من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر استخدام البنيه
التحتيه للشبكه الاوكرانيه امر مكنها من
استخدام انواع جديده من الاسلحه
السيبرانيه وبشكل سري اذا استهدفت الهجمات
البنى التحتيه الحيويه الروسيه
بالمقابل تتهم واشنطن موسكو بشان هجمات
سيبرانيه واختراق كاميرات امنيه اوكرانيه
خاصه لجمع معلومات استخباراتيه حول عبور
قوافل الامدادات العسكريه
الحكومه الروسيه وقراصنه مدعومون حكوميا
يواصلون تنفيذه هجمات ضد انظمه تكنولوجيا
معلومات اوكرانيه في اطار غزو الروسي
الاوكرانيا
وفقا لجهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي واشنطن
تقدم اوكرانيا على انها وراء الهجمات
السيبرانيه من خلال مجموعه اي تي اي
الى جانب تطوير هجمات بمشاركه
جي ان جي الجورجيه اضافه لمجموعات في
تركيا وبولندا
وبينما تتجمد جبهات القتال على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بانتظار هجوم الربيع تبدو
الحرب اكثر حراره بين المتحاربين
الصبرانيه حرب وان كانت في الخفاء لكنها
تقض مضاجع الكبار وبلا نهر
[موسيقى]
شهدت العاصمه الاردنيه عمان هطول امطار
غزيره ادت الى ارتفاع منسوب المياه في عدد
من شوارع المدينه ونشر موقع طقس العرب
مقاطع مصوره لحاله الطرق في عده احياء
بعمان واظهرت المقاطع غرق بعض الشوارع
وتشهد البلاد منخفضا جويا من الدرجه
الثالثه وفقا للارصاد الجويه الاردنيه
[موسيقى]
تعود الى امريكا الان في اخبار الساعه حيث
انتشر فيديو لرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مازح
فيه الحضور خلال القائه كلمه في جامعه
اوليستر في ايرلندا الشماليه يتحدث فيه عن
مصمم البيت الابيض لافتا الى انه ايرلندي
وكان بايدن يقصد المصمم والمهندس المعماري
جيمس هوبن والذي قام بتصميمه وانشاء
العديد من المباني لكن يبقى البيت الابيض
الابرز من بينها
انا
بهذا تنتهي اخبار الساعه خصصنا جلها
لموضوع توقيف المسؤوله والمجتمع به عن
التسريبات شكرا على المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات